Robert Habeck ist der unfähigste
Wirtschaftsminister in der Geschichte
Deutschland warum sage ich das also wer
im Fernsehen sagt dass ein Bäcker nur
mal zwei drei Monate nicht produzieren
muss und es passiert ja nicht also der
kann es nicht wir brauchen nicht über
die Pendlerpauschale sprechen die hat er
ja auch mal wunderbar erklärt oder nicht
erklärt und ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen
wir haben ein Energie und ein
Wirtschaftskrieg ja den Leuten geht es
schlecht und er führt Sandkasten Spiele
durch das heißt anstatt wirklich jede
Klima Stunde zu nutzen jedes
Atomkraftwerk jedes Kohlekraftwerk die
Chinesen Bauten dieses Jahr 300
Kohlekraftwerke und wir sträuben uns
alles zu nutzen damit wir diese
Energiekrise auch überwinden die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger werden frieren
und die Grünen haben Schuld das müssen
sie nur wissen und ich finde es
unsäglich dass auch der
Ministerpräsident in Niedersachsen weil
damit sie und sagt ja Niedersachsen
geht's gut was mit den anderen
Bundesländern ist interessiert ihn
eigentlich gar nicht und das ist so
schade und wir werden sehen wenn die
Wahlen am Sonntag vorbei sind wird auch
das AKW in Niedersachsen wieder mit
reinkommen aber ich finde es total
unsichtlich weil so funktioniert es eben
nicht Herr dohrendorf the pioneer des
median Startup von Gabor Steinmann
kannst auch mit den vier Männern die
haben mir letztens im Pioneer Briefing
auch geschrieben er war der Star der
deutschen Wirtschaft wann war er habe
ich denn eigentlich der Star der
deutschen Wirtschaft das habe ich mich
direkt gefragt beim lesen weil sie sagen
jetzt unfähig der Wirtschaftsminister in
Deutschland die Malz hatte hat die
Wirtschaft den denn so sehr gefeiert sie
sind selbstunternehmer also ich kann das
nicht so empfinden er war bei den
damenkammer sehr gut an ja aber ich muss
auch ganz ehrlich sagen was man jetzt
hört ja wir haben 2000 Mitarbeiter im
Ministerium Wirtschaftsministerium und
auch ein Altmaier hat den ein oder
anderen Kopf mal entlassen und einen
neuen besetzt aber was habe ich jetzt
gerade gemacht hat er hat die die die
Ökonomen die Wirtschaftswissenschaftler
alle entlassen und hat jetzt neue Leute
drauf gesetzt seine Leute
aus den aus dem Windkraft Energie
Seiteneinsteiger die brauchen wir
garantiert nicht sondern wir brauchen
wirklich wissenschaftliche fachliche
Expertise im Vergleich zu setzen
beispielsweise Finanzminister Christian
Lindner hat die auch behalten erstmal
die aus dem alten Ministerium Robert
Habeck anscheinend hat aber gedacht er
könnte es besser alle raus da muss ihn
keiner zum Minister machen wenn sie
jetzt aber der Berater von Habeck wenn
es ich weiß es relativ schwierig sie
haben gesagt er ist sehr unfähigste
Wirtschaftsminister in Deutschland
jemals hatte aber wenn sie jetzt der
Berater werden würden sie noch den Kurs
schaffen habe ich umzudrehen was müsste
er jetzt tun nein ich würde es nicht
schaffen also da habe ich wirklich
da habe ich keine Hoffnung ich muss auch
ganz ehrlich sagen auch die Grünen
insgesamt ja auch diese Dame die ja auch
immer überall so schön im Fernsehen ist
die Vorsitzende der Grünen genau acht
Jahre studiert oder 7 Jahre nie etwas
gearbeitet nie gelernt das hat man auch
bei anderen Parteien aber das mag sein
aber ich kritisiere das bei unseren
Parteien ganz genauso aber solche Leute
sind bei uns jetzt an der Macht nur in
Deutschland führen nein und dann sehen
Sie diese Verlogenheit ja ich sage jetzt
nur mal die die Prämie in der corner
Prämie die die wirklich gestaltet wurden
war um Kassiererin Polizisten oder auch
die im Homeoffice Arbeiten zu unter
finanziell zu unterstützen und die die
die die der der Bundesvorstand genehmigt
sich selbst diese größte 1500 € einmalig
diese Bonuszahlung auch wenn es nachher
zurückgezahlt haben ist doch verlogen da
kann man doch nur sehen dann geht's nur
ums Geld leider und um reine Ideologie
denn das was sie vor zehn Jahren mal
gesagt haben da kommen sie ja jetzt
langsam hin hier frage ich einmal gerne
Herrn Boldt scheitern die Grünen denn
jetzt an ihren eigenen Ansprüchen weil
wenn man an die Grünen denkt denkt man
ja eigentlich an Grün und keine
Atomkraftwerke Kohlekraftwerke auch
schon gar nicht scheitern die Grünen
jetzt an den eigenen Ansprüchen ist die
Zeit in der wir im Augenblick Leben
wirklich wahnsinnig spannend weil die
beiden fundamentalen Ideologie mit der
Grünen jetzt auf dem Prüfstand sind
Pazifismus und eben Anti-Atom
beides im Grunde müsste überdacht werden
oder müsste vollkommen neu gedacht
werden von den Grünen sie werden es aber
an das Teil nicht ins Skepsis niemals
tun weil das auch ihr Gründungsmythos
ist ihre Identität ausmacht denn die
Grünen sind keine politische Partei
sondern sie sind eine religiöse Sekte
und das erklärt auch warum es ihre
Anhänger bei Ihnen bleiben selbst wenn
alles den Bach runtergeht also sie
werden immer diese 15 Prozent bekommen
selbst wenn
wirtschaftlich immer immer schlimmer
wird weil es bei den Grünen um Themen
geht die mit Wirtschaftspolitik oder so
gar nicht einzuholen sind die da gar
nicht diskutiert werden können das sind
Themen die wie soll man sagen
metaphysisch sind oder wirklich
theologisch sind und die im Grunde etwas
zu tun haben auch mit dieser Vorstellung
wir das kleine Deutschland also diese
wenigen Leute die hier leben wir könnten
Vorbild sein für die ganze Welt und wir
Patienten die Welt retten wir könnten im
Grunde vorangehen dass er ihres
Lieblingswort dieser Leute wir gehen
voran in der Hoffnung dass uns die ganze
Welt folgt das ist ein das ist ein
messian ja es ist freundlich formuliert
eigentlich ist es sogar eine Art
missionarisches Bewusstsein ja nur wir
sehen klar auch im Blick auf den Rest
von Europa von der ganzen restlichen
Welt ganz zu schweigen wir sind die
einzigen die die Probleme richtig sehen
rätselhafter Weise folgen uns die
anderen noch nicht aber wir müssen
weitergehen das ist mehr oder Nein
ja würde ich auf jeden Fall sagen ich
habe einen Großteil meines Lebens im
Ausland gelebt und diese ja wie sie
sagen zu dieser missionarische Eifer und
dieser Glaube so wir haben so die die
heilsidee das hat ja auch wie man bei zu
sehr schlimmen Sachen in der Geschichte
führt was ich jetzt überhaupt nicht mit
den Grünen gleichsetzen möchte
keinesfalls aber das ist schon sehr
typisch für für uns oder für sehr viele
Deutsche also Menschen woanders auf der
Welt sind da oft sehr sehr viel
pragmatischer einfach ich finde schon
spannend Leute die Frage sehr
aufgeworfen haben wenn jetzt die Grünen
eigentlich demaskiert oder werden die
Wähler jetzt abrücken sie verneinen das
ich finde es interessant weil es sind ja
eigentlich extrem links und lang hat man
eben gedacht ja gut wenn man nicht
unbedingt links will aber grün das geht
das ist die Umweltschutz klar gut ich
ich teile Ihre Auffassung insofern das
wirklich religiöse Züge hat aber es geht
über die Grünen hinaus immer die ganze
Klima der klimawand ich sage es ist auch
eine Klima Religion das ist unglaublich
man muss an diesen Glaubenssatz denken
ich erinnere mich da komme ich zurück
auf ihre These dass mir nicht mehr offen
diskutiert vor 5 oder 10 Jahren habe ich
noch ernsthaft diskutiert ja Klimawandel
Mensch gemacht ja nein wenn wenn es
gemacht müsste man sagt wie groß ist der
Anteil daran das ist vollkommen aus
Diskussion verschwunden wie wir denken
gar nicht mehr darüber nach wir sagen
nur noch das sind die Klimaziele die
müssen vielleicht und jetzt kommt eben
das das grüne und das autoritäre kommen
ganz gefährlich zusammen da kommt eben
der Vater Starter bin ich über meine
wieder Freiheit einschränken du darfst
nicht Autofahren dein Porsche muss in
der Garage bleiben ganz schlimm du musst
auf das Velo umsteigen und da kann man
über die absurden Widersprüche dann eben
dass man jetzt merkt ah okay Kernkraft
ist vielleicht doch sie eigentlich doch
lieber freundlich eigentlich gut oder
jetzt wieder Kohle anstellen das ist
dermaßen widersprüchlich und eigentlich
müsste jeder jetzt entdecken und sagen
nein diese Politik das geht nicht auch
gehen wir zurück zur Vernunft seine
vernünftigen bürgerlichen liberalen
Politik aber ich glaube auch ich sehe
sie ich bin das skeptisch dass das große
Erwachen kommt das Leiden muss offenbar
noch viel größ